jay look at this
it's ruined stella she chew on my shoe
you have to discipline that stupid dog
i discipline her all the time oh really
how by buying her little cupcakes
they're not real cupcakes they're doggy
treats in the form of cupcakes yeah you
should have told that to manny before he
ate one oh come on his coat never looked
better
you wouldn't find this so funny if she
was destroying your shoes well i don't
leave my shoes laying around so
so it's my fault that she chooses to do
my shoe
i didn't say that you barely said it you
have to stop quartering her i don't call
her
what she tries to drink the water
it's funny i don't know a cup of soup a
cup salad
yeah i have bacon i can't i don't have
all day to
describe all my meals to
eating on my things you stupid animal
no cannot you i'll call you back bad
doggy
do you want to chew on something okay
okay okay
look at this look at this delicious
men's shoe eat it come on eat it
eat it yummy
it is you come on eating yum yum yum yum
oh please i'm sorry you had to see this
i've seen him do a lot of crazy stuff
but this is a whole new level
is this a people cookie you're good a
definitive yes or no would be
appreciated those cupcakes did a number
on me
are you happy you have reduced me into a
person who eats a shoe
glorious do you think this is funny to
talk to me like i am
a dog i'm not talking to you like you're
a dog i'm just asking you to sit so we
can get to the bottom of this
okay fine good girl
come on you set me up gloria why are you
acting so crazy
it's just a little dog he's not the
little dog that is making me crazy it's
you that is making me crazy me
yeah you used to put me first you used
to want me in that shower
should i be here for this no man it's
okay i go but i want you to know this
where i come from manchester woman it
goes wife
mistress dog dog always at the bottom
stella
where's my good girl
gloria still up there no
but i am why don't you say hello to your
wife when you come home well why don't
you greet me at the door wagging your
tail
stella honey where are you stella
my baby stella i'm coming
i'm coming
okay you okay why are you swimming in
your clothes
because i'm self-conscious about my body
stella fell in the pool
it's my fault i let her out and then i
got caught up in my couponing
any coupons for swim lessons cause
stella needs some seriously
manny you teach to swim by throwing him
in the pool but the dog gets swimming
lessons
i gotta say it was unpleasant but
effective we have to teach stella how to
swim otherwise she could drown
why don't you teach her not to jump in
the pool she didn't jump in the pool she
fell in the pool
why suddenly would she jump in the pool
when she doesn't know how to swim why
does she bark at the vacuum
it's a thing is never going to play with
you
are you saying that stella is stupid are
you covering her ears
let's have a little compassion she's
probably still traumatized from her
near-death experience
again what's happening i know
hey
hey what what's wrong
me i'm sorry
[Applause]
[Laughter]
look at her come on we said no stella in
the bed
but she's just a little puppy she
probably got scared and snuck in
oh really how come when manny has
neighbors you don't let him snuck in the
bed all right at six o'clock in the
morning can we talk about this later
answer the question jay
did you find what you were looking for
no
she's a waitress at the club her
boyfriend crashed her car
so i helped her because we have that fun
game where i order salad and she brings
me french fries
but i never dreamt of her last night i
had a nightmare joe got out onto a ledge
of a tall building i couldn't get to him
i was very upset i think i might have
cried a little in my sleep
which might have sounded like sex to you
which i don't love
but that's the baby i was talking about
really
that's scary yes why in god's name would
i need to dream about another woman
now that you say it out loud it does
seem kind of crazy
i'm not proud of this but the dream
wasn't about joe
it was about this little baby right here
that's right
you almost fell off a ledge and dead he
was so scared
you're a perfectly fine dog i don't hate
you
estella okay i was a little mean to you
but there's no reason to kill yourself
you are young you still have so much
left to smell
right i am how you gonna go i'm coming
i'm manny
what happened are you okay she did it
again
and you jumped in to save her no yay i
wanted to take a little swim before
going to the wedding get her a towel
she's shaking like a leaf
oh no no i meant i meant thank you jay
the dog towel for me for the wife
we're back funniest thing stella fell in
love with this dog on our wall just
stared at it lovingly
turned out to be her reflection in a
hubcap can you blame her
i got an a on my history exam by the way
really you're competing with the dog
don't let it bother you girl jay we need
to talk
i went to the allergies today and he
thinks that joe's rash
is an allergy what a surprise an
allergist found an allergy he thinks
he might be allergic to stella what the
only reaction this dog gives people is
the giggles
i mean when she tried to lick her own
face in my village if a goat acted that
dumb
we wouldn't even eat it this allergy
thing is very serious
we need to separate them for a week to
see if the rash goes away i don't know
if i can go that long without seeing joe
no
joe the dog i already call mitch and cam
and they're gonna take her for a week
she'll be traumatized she's very
sensitive she scrapes her butt on the
driveway why don't you like her she's
never done anything to you
hi look my face cream
you know how much this costs no how much
don't change the subject the dog goes
now
you know now that i think about it i
could be allergic to stella
i've been a little stuffy since we got
her you were stuffy long before stella
do you not remember scolding that waiter
at chuck e cheese for serving you from
the right
once sonia blew up my valentine's day i
could have sat around feeling sorry for
myself
instead i had a little chuckle and i got
the dog a gift
i know it's silly getting stella a
present so close to her birthday
is she around i think she's upstairs in
the bath but i just gave her a bath this
morning
ew oh you're talking about stella wait
you got the dog a gift
a lot of attitude for a guy whose date's
a tub of ice cream and a fuzzy robe
you're spending valentine's day in a
kathy cartoon
yeah i'm i'm sorry miles no i apologize
to the guys it's just i'm too tired to
play golf
damn it's a dog food
ah stella this is your lucky day
gloria makes this colombian dish i loved
when we were first dating
i lied about a lot of things back then
what the hell are you doing that takes
me three
days three days to prepare and then you
say that you love it and you feed it to
the dog
what else have you been lying about jay
kennedy pritchett
go no daddy kisses till sunday after she
eats this
oh you're cooking us a steak dinner how
sweet yeah i came home from work early
to cook us dinner that's crazy
this is for stella hi jay you don't know
what i'm competing with over there
cameron's wooing her with belly rubs
jewelry kisses on the mouth
i just want her to remember who loves
her the most i don't think stella is
ever going to forget
how much you love her no matter how much
time she needs to stay with mitch and
cam
what are you talking about she's coming
home friday that's the thing look
the rush is gone oh we don't know that
stella
a lot of things cause rashes maybe he's
less stressed this week than last
what's going on we have to get rid of
estella slow down
we haven't decided anything yet yes we
have is what's best for joe
and for whatever it's worth my eyes have
stopped itching i could taste my food
and i have more energy you took a
three-hour nap yesterday
i was tired from the marathon the
downton abbey marathon that family is
exhausting i can't believe this
uh jay i'm so sorry maybe you can get
the fish
cause it's so much cuter driving down
the road with your fish's head sticking
out the window
fish
you